est ce que quelqu'un quelque chose
contre le fait de commencer avec le film
de jean marie poiré le père noël est une
ordure
moi je suis tout à fait contre quand le
fait d'en parler ou quand on le fait
d'en parler parce que c'est un film qui
devrait beaucoup mieux passée sous
silence
et pourquoi parce que c'est un film
épouvantablement mauvais c'est une
resucée d'un mauvais spectacle de
café-théâtre et monsieur jean marie
poiré n'y a jamais eu le moindre talent
il n'entend pas davantage en cette
occasion vous avez eu la pièce en
sciences
oui c'est vous avez vu la longueur je
trouvais tout de même assez drôle parce
que quand même c'était sur la scène du
café théâtre mais sur l'écran alors ça
n'a plus aucun intérêt
ça ne vous ai pas fait rire pour
l'instant si je dois dire qu'autour de
moi c'était tous un peu plus l'air il y
avait en effet des gays qui s'exclame
fait comme on dit bombay a dégradé à des
plaisanteries de garçons de bain qui
vous me verrez c'est quand même d'une
bassesse assez indigne vous méprisez le
populaire je ne méprise pas du tout au
plus les reportages à tour et défendu le
cinéma populaire mais par les
inconditionnels du cinéma populaire mais
à la condition de ne pas tomber dans la
plus épouvantable de vulgarité ce qui
est exactement le cas pour ce film bien
je crois qu'il faut pas s'y fier oui je
crois qu'il faut préciser que c'est de
l'humour bête et méchant alors comme
george north
je pratique tout le temps il y avait
urgence des moyens il n'a pas aimé
finances forestier tu dis des conneries
comme d'habitude j'adore j'adore le bête
et méchant quand il est vraiment bête et
méchant là ce n'est ni bête et méchant
c'est simplement complètement un v6 est
intelligente et gentille
non c'est complètement imbécile
simplement cela ni bête mais ans est un
vaisseau non c'est vrai que c'est pas du
grand cinéma que je n'aurais pas du tout
moi tant plaisir mais je trouve une
qualité dans le film quand même une
qualité et qui est due surtout aux
acteurs je crois qu'ils sont ronds les
gones et gérard jugnot et ca1 et mme
josiane balasko christian clavier ont
rompu à ce genre d'exercice et ils ont
trouvé le rythme pour la première fois
ce qui avait pas dans les bronzés ce
qu'il ya un espèce de rythme ça va vite
on s'amuse bon c'est vrai si on n'aime
pas ça mon restrictif et on reste à
l'extérieur
quoi qu'il faut dire un petit mot de
l'intrigué qui est assez lâche faut bien
le dire c'est un noël
oui c'est une loi qui est la schl en
parlant pas pascal et est-ce qu'il
arrive dans cette émission qu'on puisse
faire une phrase on est interrompu leur
chance
c'est pas possible on montre nathan part
du père noël non parce que moi je bous
autant le savoir forestier reprenait
c'était une nuit de noël dans un bureau
spécialement triste qui est consacrée à
sos amitié dont il ya des gens qui
appellent en disant je suis malheureux
qu'est ce que je dois faire et dans ce
bureau où l'on se regroupe et un un père
noël c'est à dire un type qui est libéré
de prison alcoolique et ou qui jouent
les père noël qui distribuent des tracts
pour une boîte de strip-tease
il ya sa femme qui est enceinte qui
balaye un landau et tu verras il ya un
travelo il ya bon et tout ça va très
vite et d'espèces de répliques
d'échangés ça va se terminer par un
assassinat et il faut se débarrasser du
cadavre on s'en débarrassera au zoo en
faisant des petits paquets cadeaux bon
c'est on le prend comme on veut c'est
vrai que c'est pas du grand cinéma
encore une fois moi je pense qu'on peut
s'y amuser moi j'ai plutôt souri à deux
ou trois répliques et notamment
notamment au personnage de gérard jugnot
que je trouve un acteur vraiment
exceptionnel merci pour cette fragile
michel ciment moi je t'ai dit michel
simon avait demandé la parole et puis
arrivé moi je trouve je suis entré entre
les deux soeurs je trouve que
effectivement d'abord le café des arts à
renouveler cinéma français on le sait
par miu miu par-devers part de perthuis
par beaucoup de michel blanc et jugnot
et c'est comme dans les bronzés il ya
dans ce film énormément de moments très
drôles des répliques
il y a un esprit loufoque et une
fantaisie qui n'existe pas dans la
tradition de la comédie à la française
est une fantaisie un peu sur réalisant
il ya de l'humour noir ça et un cours
des salons et des moments très drôles ce
qui manque c'est un cinéaste et même un
scénariste dire que les mêmes situations
peuvent à transposer directement du café
théâtre au cinéma les mêmes situations
enchaîné avec un sens le rite que je ne
trouve pas tellement dans ce film mais
on pense a dit à des films de dino risi
on sait ce que dino risi vous avec de
grands comédiens qui venait aussi du cac
car toute la comédie italienne via non
pas du café théâtre italien mais du
music hall et le cinéma comique thann
étaient renouvelés par le music hall en
france qui manque c'est des metteurs en
scène qui de grand talent comme
l'hérésie par exemple en italie où les
monicelli qui utilisent ces comédiens
qui travaille avec quatre ou cinq
scénaristes pendant un an un scénario et
qui leur donne matijas as donné mais il
est incontestable qu'il ya des moments
extrêmement drôle et qu'il ya un
potentiel comique chez ces acteurs qui
sont en train de renouveler la comédie
en france
mais précisément ça se limite
actuellement ils sont au bout du rouleau
ils n'ont plus rien à dire ils n'ont
plus aucune invention ils en sont
réduits à porter à l'écran des pièces
curieux de succès dans leurs missiles a
rejeté le cinéma américain porte t elle
mardi
des pièces de broadway et il na n'est
pas mort au contraire non mais c'est
bien mais c'est assez monsieur chambrée
pour apprendre est qu'il peut faire ça
entre nous on n'a jamais la question
d'accord avec toi que si jean marie
poiré a été remplacé par dino risi bombe
alors mieux
d'accord c'est l'art cinéma il sait pas
si mal que ça et c'est plutôt mieux que
le gendarme
on a fini le clip et de fond qui est
fait c'est la critique contre les
plaisanteries de garçons de bain
moi je suis un défenseur de
plaisanteries de garçon sage il ya le
divin enfant dont les intrigues potache
mais une plaisanterie de potache n'est
jamais drôle en soit c'est sa
grossièreté justement qui j'aimerais
bien donc il ya une contradiction on ne
peut pas des choses qui sont autant ne
doit pas passer l'après-midi puis
démissionne enregistrée sur le père noël
est une ordure de jean marie poiré
mais je les incidents comme ans est un
projecteur de plusieurs centaines de
kilos deloitte qui vient d'exploser
quand on regarde son sang froid
vous en arrivez à faire exploser les
project alors repensé contenir
[Musique]